[Music]
when it comes to Great shown in anime
the heart and soul are undoubtedly the
battles and one piece as a heavyweight
in this genre has shattered all
Frontiers with the incredible and
sometimes downright crazy events of the
wano arc but before we dive into the
juicy details let's take a moment to
remember some of the alltime greatest
fights in this epic adventure so without
any more delay here's Vin tube's top 20
one piece
fights kicking off our top 20 is the
high stakes clash between Sanji the
culinary genius and the crafty cp9 agent
Jabra while Sanji may not be at the
Forefront of every pivotal battle like
his counterpart Zoro his contribution is
undeniably crucial after a humiliating
defeat at the hands of cp9 agent Khalifa
the swirly eyebrowed Chef makes a
triumphant comeback by Saving Uso from
certain death and engaging in a fierce
Showdown with Jabra now the cipher Paul
number n or cp9 is no trifling adversary
these covert assassins who work for the
world government are elite soldiers
skilled in rosiki a form of superhuman
martial arts what makes this showdown
Stand Out is that at the time Sanji
hadn't yet mastered the Skywalk an
advanced variant of the rokos Shiki
technique Geo despite this he relies
solely on his Speed and Agility to
orchestrate a spectacular takedown of
Jabra that leaves observers unable to
distinguish his moves from those of a
Geo
user
who can forget the heartwarming moment
when Luffy places his treasured straw
hat at top nami's head while she
tearfully begs for
help our pick for the 19th spot is
Luffy's first confrontation with a
Bonafide villain despite arlong's
physical prowess as a fish man his crazy
rapidly regenerating shark teeth as well
as his menacing sword Nothing Stops
Luffy from handing him a solid beating
to this day this Jewel remains one of
the most satisfying acts of Revenge in
the first half of the one piece Saga the
image of nami's possessions being
shattered and arlong park reduced to a
heap of rubble is forever etched in our
minds as one of those Unforgettable
moments where we as fans stand in unity
with the straw hats in both heart and
[Music]
spirit
a next up is a clash of the Gods NL the
self-proclaimed God of skypia faces off
against Straw Hat
Luffy now that we're aware of Luffy's
newly awakened sun god Nika Powers this
early Showdown seemed to foreshadow
gumgum fruit's hidden potential and
Luffy's immunity to electricity enna
Wheels the loia type Rumble Rumble fruit
granting him control over lightning but
here's the twist Luffy's rubbery body
makes him nl's worst nightmare despite
the hype around nl's Invincible fruit he
barely scratches Luffy instead he finds
himself squashed between Luffy's
gigantic golden punch and the chandor
and belfrey that's not underestimate en
all though his powers can fry opponents
of the caliber of Zoro Sanji and wiper
and he's also capable of wiping out
entire Sky Islands using the ark Maxim
to supercharge his attacks in addition
to his outrageous God complex NL doesn't
play for any team neither the Pirates
nor the world government so this makes
him one of the most intriguing baddies
to appear so early in the series and
we're eagerly waiting to see if he's
going to make a
comeback in our next showdown at number
17 Luffy faces off once again against
the loia user and this time it's none
other than the former M shichibukai and
head of Barack Works sir
crocodile in the backdrop of a raging
rebellion and hidden conspiracies in the
Kingdom of arabasta this Clash stands as
one of the most heart pounding moments
in one piece history our easygoing
Captain is defeated twice by the
formidable crocodile and pushed to the
brink of death on both occasions Luffy's
unconventional solution to counter the
warlord Sans and fruit Powers which
involves consuming copious amounts of
water captures his zany nature perfectly
but also turns out to be a clever tactic
these comical moments seemingly merge
with the grittier third Act of the
battle where Luffy soldiers on despite
being battered and poisoned at the heart
of this Clash lies a central theme that
has always defined the straw Hat's
Legacy their unwavering commitment to
Justice and selflessness especially when
it comes to the nakama and this battle
serves as a powerful example of that
Bedrock
principle
[Music]
up next is the only Clash where the
entire straw ha hat crew square off
against the colossal zombie ORS brought
back to life by the shii buai gecko
Moria
power I get killed
orz while alive was known as the
continent puller for a reason and this
battle is no walk in the park what makes
things interesting though is that the
revived ORS has been given Luffy stolen
Shadow the match seems almost like a
test to see how the crew measures up to
their captain and boy does it hint at
just how much they fall short of Luffy's
Incredible strength especially when we
fast forward to the sodak but here's the
kicker while the straw hats crew might
not match up to their Captain the battle
is a shining example of their awesome
team teamwork spot-on strategy and a
seriously impressive display of each
member's skills and strengths they take
on the impossible and give it everything
they've got and a little more till
nightmare Luffy arrives to save the
day at number 15 is the heartbreaking
confrontation between between two close
friends and crew mates Luffy and
Uso stemming from an argument over
changing ships Uso who's deeply affected
and angered by the decision to take part
with the mergo challenges his captain to
a jewel it's a tearjerker no doubt
however it's through this man-to-man
fight that the two seem to mature almost
overnight this new found maturity helps
them set aside their differences for
Robin's sake Stam side by side as they
issue a reckless but Brave challenge to
the world government although the tussle
between Luffy and Usopp is a landmark
moment in their Journey as pirates we're
pretty sure we don't want to witness a
similar situation between the other
members of the crew and for that we have
our fingers firmly
[Applause]
crossed
at number 14 enter the deceptively
likable kizaru as he toys with four of
the supernovas basil Hawkins urouge X
Drake and scratchman apple in a lopsided
cat and mouse
game
[Music]
the Marine Admiral's entrance riding a
cannonball like a true showstopper
instantly throws everyone for a loop
with his laid-back attitude emotionless
gaze and the amusing charade of
struggling with a denden Mushi what sets
kizaru apart from Admirals like aiji
who's known for his unwavering moral
code or the authoritarian Akainu is his
enigmatic stance on principles and
beliefs it's this uncertainty that makes
him a menacing figure his Mastery over
the loia power of light only enhances
his ability to casually play with the
super rookies effectively tarnishing
their budding reputations what truly
baffles onlookers is kizaru's seeming
lack of interest in finishing off his
woefully mismatched opponents he
approaches his duties with a
half-hearted demeanor like someone going
through the motions of a dull office job
the next time we cross paths with this
Admiral we can't help but wonder which
side of his personality will
[Music]
emerge
for our picket number 13 let's backtrack
to the Dress Rossa Arc where Zoro
confronts Pika the top executive of the
donkeyote
Pirates Pika makes the terrible mistake
of underestimating Zoro totally
overlooking the second strongest member
of the straw hats while thinking that
only Luffy and God Uso are the big
threats amongst the crew right from the
get-go P's powers of the stone stone
fruit which can reshape entire
Landscapes and allow him to transform
into a gigantic Stone Golem give the
battle an epic feel but honestly when
you're up against someone like Pica who
relies on sneaky tactics like targeting
the vulnerable it's quite clear that
Zoro has the upper hand on closer
inspection of the moment when Zoro
finally slices Pika in half we realize
it's the same attack he initially used
against dracu mihawk the world's
greatest swordsman this is truly an eye
opener of zoro's immense growth since
that early encounter with mihawk and
there's more Zoro infuses his three
swords with haki a concept not
previously explored but later elaborated
upon in the W work these elements add a
whole new layer of significance to the
fight making it more than your average
[Music]
showdown in the midst of the series most
colossal allout War One jeel stands out
it's the face off between Edward Newgate
AKA Whitebeard and Marine Admiral Akainu
which is our pick for number
[Music]
12 the death of Port Gast D ace at the
hands of the Admiral demands serious
payback and that's exactly what
unleashes whitebeard's uncontainable
wrath here we witness the full extent of
whitebeard's tremor Tremor fruit power
as Ayu endures a devastating blow to his
side which obliterates the formidable
Marine headquarters in its wake despite
sustaining two Grievous chest wounds and
battling a chronic illness the veteran
pyate overpowers a high ranking Marine
as if it was just Child's Play one can
only imagine the overwhelming strength
Whitebeard must have possessed in his
prime in his attempts to retaliate Ayu
manages to singe the old man's whiskers
and nothing more really this
confrontation serves as an unforgettable
Testament not only to whitebeard's
unmatched might but also to the
incredible resilience of the marinees
top
[Music]
ranks in yet another emotionally charged
Showdown the 11th position features the
Revenge match between the red scabbards
and the formidable yongo kaido
these nine loyal retainers have returned
after two decades of suffering to
liberate their Homeland from the
clutches of the Azo Dragon initially
their assault seems promising as their
unwavering resolve and impressive
individual combat Styles shine through
however the lack of power becomes
painfully evident when compared to
kaido's monstrous might nevertheless
this doesn't diminish the Dignity of
their Endeavor they launch a second
beautifully choreographed assault
employing Odin's signature Jewel sword
attack with a triumphant Cry of Odin
they put their lives on the line and
even in defeat their honor remains
unblemished a true samurai till the
end
returning to the Dress Rossa Arc at the
halfway mark Luffy and Trafalga law
engage in a daring confrontation with
Don kote doflamingo hit
[Music]
the if we were to summarize this battle
in just one word it would be gutsy this
Clash is about more than just settling a
score for law who's out for Revenge
after do Flamingo has his mentor Don
kyote rosinante killed it's a fight that
sends shock waves through the onepiece
World by taking on doy a confirmed Ally
of the world government with a yonko's
backing Luffy and law inadvertently
thrust themselves into the world
government spotlight they're seen not
only as liberators of an oppressed
Nation but also as a disruptive force
that divides the Marines with some
members questioning the true meaning of
Justice when it comes to the battle
itself it's a nail-biting marathon of
techniques with Luffy lore and their
opponent pulling out all the Stops Plus
for the first time ever we get a glimpse
of a devil fruits awakened form in
action in a nutshell this final showdown
in dress Rosser is a game changer for
the straw hats setting the stage for
even bigger Adventures
[Music]
[Applause]
ahead next we travel to the picturesque
region of Ringo as Zoro squares off
against gamazo the manslayer who turns
out to be killer from the kid
pirates with a pristine snowscape a
wooden bridge and a distressed o run
this is a quintessentially Japanese
scene perfectly tailored for the green
head swordsman to add some trivia Ringo
was once ruled by zoro's great uncle the
late Dao shimoto ushimaru which lands a
historical layer to this epic Jewel
making it even more compelling though
Zoro rescues kuki Odin's daughter hiori
from harm during this encounter and
that's not all he uses two swords
instead of his customary three to battle
killer who just so happens to be the
only other non-ap member of the worst
generation besides himself in a
remarkable twist Zoro manages to disarm
Killer by taking his Scythe even as he's
being stabbed securing a decisive
advantage and swiftly defeating his
opponent this beautifully choreograph
sequence brings together all these
elements in one simple fluid motion
almost like a
painting Charlotte gataki takes on Luffy
at number eight while the term sweet
Commander might sound enchanting and
harmless don't let it fool you
especially when the title belongs to a
top commander and Son of the PowerHouse
yonko big mom
one of the longest fights in one piece
this Hy spectacle shows the opponents
exhibit their Mastery over all three
hary forms until Luffy hits the war with
gatak Good's Advanced observation haki
what makes gataki a nightmare for Luffy
is the Striking resemblance in their
abilities and their indomitable fighting
Spirit katakuri having consumed the
mochi mochi fruit wields his devil fruit
powers in a manner uncanny similar to
Luffy's elastic techniques but what
Luffy can do well gataki can do even
better both possess the rare conqueror's
hary and the Armament Hy is evenly
matched however it's katakuri's finally
honed observation hary with which he can
glimpse into the immediate future that
presents Luffy with his most daunting
challenge yet but as one who is destined
to be the king of pirates Luffy staying
true to his persevering character pulls
off a seemingly impossible win against a
rival who's never tasted defeat before
four what makes this Victory above the
ordinary is that it's a lesson in
camarad and honor an incredibly rare
thing in the pirate World
[Music]
K things get funky as we gear up for the
next big matchup at only gashima which
takes the next spot
Queen one of kaido's all stars faces off
against Sanji the Wonder Boy with
genetic enhancements when Sanji dons the
germa raid suit his latent genetic
upgrades awaken unlike Zoro or Luffy
though Sanji hasn't had as many powerups
in the past but this time things are
different capable of withstanding a
powerful Blow To The Head and shattering
Queen's sword instead sanji's endurance
and durability Skyrocket yet afraid of
losing his Humanity Sanji chooses to
discard the suit instead he devises an
advanced version of his Dia jambe
harnessing the power of His Newfound
enhancements and armorment hary to craft
the Searing hot Ifrit jambe as a name
suggests the Flames emanating from this
technique which are named after the
fiery gin of Arabic folklore seem to
hail from the depths of Hell itself
despite his formidable Zan type
Brachiosaurus body bolstered with
cybernetics Queen finds himself on the
receiving end of a a severe beating
although this Clash takes a backseat to
the more spectacular showdown between
King and Zoro witnessing Sanji move with
new found almost imperceptible speed is
breathtaking we eagerly await sanji's
next Lightning Fast display with baited
[Music]
breath
next pick is easily the most brutal
clash in wano to rescue Sanji Robin
walks into an obvious trap set by Toby
Ropo black
Maria ostracized and hunted down due to
her ability to decipher poneglyphs
Robin's not only pursued by the world
government but also coveted by powerful
Pirates like kaido and big mom all
seeking The elusive island of laugh tale
despite black Maria's usual playful
manner she shows no mercy to Robin
relentlessly unleashing her oira
knuckles in a bruising assault it's not
just the sheer physicality of the combat
that sets this Jewel apart but the
cruelty with which black Maria torments
Robin including plans to mutilate her
body and just leave her barely alive to
be of use to her Captain Robin usually
calm and composed Rises to the occasion
by unveiling her demonal Flur form a
direct manifestation of a epithe devil
child hands down one of the best power
upgrades in this Arc the sheer Terror
demonio Flur invokes especially the
sickening sound of black Maria's body
breaking as she's ens snared in a
grapple hold elevates this battle to one
of the most chilling sequences in the
[Music]
series moving on in stark contrast to
other Pirates the straw hats have always
fought against Injustice so this brings
us to our next pivotal
Clash Luchi a staunch advocate of dark
justice shows a complete lack of
hesitation when it comes to committing
heinous acts in pursuit of his mission
which is to eliminate Nico Robin on the
flip side we have Luffy engaged in one
of the most crucial pre-time skip
battles armed with his newly developed
Gear 2 and Gear 3 techniques he
fearlessly fronts his adversary even in
the face of a substantial power
disparity this battle is a defining
moment in Luffy's Journey marked by his
unwavering determination the scene where
Uso desperately calls out to the almost
unconscious Luffy still resonates with
pain and Desperation in our
memories
the showdown between yonko's kaido and
big mom against the worst generation
sits in fourth place and it remains one
of the most badass battle sequences in
one piece to
[Music]
date the sheer scale of this Clash
surpass is anything seen so far and is
unlikely to be surpassed anytime soon
when two yonkos take Center Stage the
very air crackles with the vibrant Aura
of their conqueror Hy standing before
them are five of the worst generation
Luffy Zoro eustus kid killer and lore
witnessing new alliances forming is
always thrilling and the presence of the
five is undeniable as they boldly
challenge the season Pirates one by one
they fra their incredible combat skills
dealing some serious damage to the yonos
Feats with we never thought were
possible in terms of teamwork and quick
thinking they're exceptional never
allowing kaido and big mom a moment's
Rite but remember we're dealing with
yonos here pirate World Giants who have
ruled for decades so kaido and big mom
once comrades in the legendary rock
Pirates during their youth display
equally Flawless teamwork capable of
unleashing devastating destruction on an
almost otherworldly scale while the five
young Pirates are spirited they face a
colossal challenge in dealing with the
two Titans together
[Music]
moving on to the top three now in the
grand line many Pirates share a common
goal to become the pirate king their
second in commands like Luffy's rightand
Zoro and kaido's Lead performer King are
equally determined to help their
captains achieve this dream which fuels
the cataclysmic battle in the third
spot you
King who boasts formidable combat skills
as a lunarian and an ancient Zan type
Pteranodon stands on a level above even
some pirate captains similarly enough
though Zoro acknowledged as one of the
most significant threats besides Luffy
by the Marines can be said to be well on
his way to surpass mihawk however zoro's
earlier confrontation with kaido at top
the scalo which left him severely
injured was barely masked by a miracle
drug more his newly acquired sword enma
constantly tests his limits with its
unpredictable Behavior despite these
considerable hindrances he matches King
blow for blow the ensuing battle is
brought to life through some seriously
stunning animation and when he finally
unleashes his conquer as haky in a
narrative strewn with many haky
Revelations zoro's display is in a world
of its own this remarkable scene is
surpassed only by his execution of the
king of Hell three sword style which
serves as his finishing move against
King's ultimate
technique today's Runners up Eclipse all
other battles with bizarre as the
prevailing theme the mere presence of
big mom is a clear indicator that things
are about to get wonderfully weird
meanwhile her opponents Lauren kid
possess powers that defy the laws of
reality however the main reason this
battle holds the number two is because
taking down a yonko is no small
feat so while Luffy is occupied with
kaido it falls to L and kid to confront
big mom remember the Havoc the pirate
matriarch wed with just one screen
during the whole cake Island Saga now we
get to witness her in full combat Glory
big Momo's formidable hary abilities as
well as her soul soul fruit Powers not
to mention her special homies Napoleon
prometh and Hera never a dull moment
with her creative Powers we see big mom
consume a year of her own lifespan to
gain incredible size and strength
dwarfing the two captains yet the
determined Euro retaliated with a flurry
of mind-blowing techniques barely
allowing the audience a moment to catch
their breath their awaken devil fruit
abilities give big mom no breathing
space it's hard to imagine any of the
worst generation facing off against this
Powerhouse even one story arc ago but
Lauren kid rise to the occasion not even
special homy misery can stop them and
the yonko is finally sent crashing in a
silent explosion marking the end of an
era and the beginning of a new
one that brings us to the final Victor
of the day as the drums of Liberation
Herald the return of Joy boy Luffy
defeats kindo in The grandest Showdown
in one
piece
from the very outset of the onigashima
raid when Luffy delivers his first
seething hary infused punch to the
eventual Awakening of his devil fruit
abilities it's been an exhilarating
roller coaster ride for fans with every
blow struck by kaido and every instance
where Luffy defies death a storm of
emotion surges within us there are
moments of comic relief like kaido
suddenly getting dead drunk to enhance
his strength and Luffy's awakened
abilities verging on the cartoonish
however what stands out the most is the
rapid evolution of Luffy's potential he
goes from infusing Armament hary into
his attacks to emitting it then
mastering conqueror haki even learning
it from kaido and ultimately unlocking
the latent powers of his devil fruit the
fight itself under goes a remarkable
transformation shifting from a vengeful
takedown of a malevolent yonko to an
exhilarating contest between two
incredibly powerful adversaries almost
bordering on a rivalry this Evolution
adds an extra layer of enjoyment to the
entire High spectacle the Revelation
that the gumgum fruit is in fact the
human human fruit model Nia serves as
the crowning moment kaido to remains a
captivating character throughout his
unexpected display of Honor when he
dispatches an interfering agent
partially redeems him and makes him more
relatable as a man who goes by his own
principles and aspirations making the
narrative all the more
engrossing
with this epic Clash now behind us Luffy
stands on the threshold of a Brand New
Vista of Adventures promising an
exciting journey ahead and with that
thought we come to the end of this video
this was the top 20 one piece fights
brought to you by VIN tube so if you
enjoyed the video you know what to do
don't you and thanks for sticking around
to the very end until next time